have you ever been driving somewhere and
suddenly realized that you were thinking
some strange thought like what birthday
balloons smell like maybe remembering a
note that you wrote to your fifth-grade
pen power something that you wish you
had said earlier on in the day basically
do you ever have a wandering mind
it can kind of feel like the opposite of
structured thought as if your brain's
GPS is on the fritz
just taking turns at random and it can
be particularly frustrating when you're
trying to focus on a problem or an idea
and two minutes later you catch yourself
wondering what it's like to be a cloud
or who invented pockets but if you
search around a bit you start hearing
stories like this one
Amy Baxter a doctor spent years looking
for ways to use cold temperatures to
help kids get through the pain of
vaccinations coming home after an
all-night shift she noticed that her
vibrating steering wheel made her hands
numb and suddenly she realized that if
you combine vibration and cold together
you could ease the pain of a shot and
afterwards she said after an overnight
shift your mind is expansive connections
are made that wouldn't otherwise happen
she basically gave credit to the fact
that she was tired in the history of
ideas this pattern is familiar intense
thinking over a long period of time with
no clear results and then in a single
moment when the minds relaxed and
drifting a perfect solution just pops in
sometimes it can happen in a bathtub
that's when Archimedes figured out how
to measure density using displaced water
or it can happen relaxing under a tree
that's when Sir Isaac Newton observed
that famous falling Apple had a sudden
understanding of gravitational force
even Albert Einstein once asked why is
it I always get my best ideas while
shaving and this can seem all a bit
accidental hard to recreate after all
how many times can you shave in a day
but it turns out that many creative
people actively search for ways to get
their brains into that wandering
the inventor Thomas Edison would try to
catch his mind and hypnagogia that weird
place between wakefulness and sleep he
would fall asleep in a chair holding
steel ball bearings in his hands at the
moment that he drifted off to sleep the
balls would hit the floor and he would
wake up sometimes with an answer to a
nagging question some inventors use
Transcendental Meditation others go on
long bike rides or wander the halls of
the museum and sometimes the key might
be something as simple as
procrastinating cleaning a bathroom or
reorganizing books in fact it's been
shown that many successful artists and
scientists procrastinate on purpose they
don't do it aim lessly though they put
off making something because they
understand the process that things have
to stew in your mind for a bit before
the connections can be made all of this
might seem a little time consuming and
messy not the step by step logical
thought process we usually equate with
genius but some of the ingredients of
genius might be just that time and
messiness so the next time you catch
yourself thinking about how balloons
smell or how rainbows always seem so far
away
don't beat yourself up you might just be
moments away from wandering into the
next great idea